well she's very much a private sector  you know she's sort of almost  anti-government um  but  yeah i mean i think that that's  certainly of topical debate i mean this  year how big should government be you  know what services should it provide  and um what's what services is it  capable of providing as well  uh  and  it's it's interesting but i do find  even in my own politics  sometimes a divorce between what i'm  what i would be recommending to the  minister of education in ghana  and then what i expect of our own  american system here right  so um  yeah i think it's just years and years  and years of ex you know expecting that  government should provide everything and  now people are saying  maybe not actually maybe there are  better  actors  in certain areas